معا انخفاض درجه الحراره ارتفعت شده
المعارك وعنفها شرقيه اوكرانيا بين طرفي
المواجهه مدينه بخمه الاستراتيجيه تشهد
قتالا عنيفا القوه الروسيه قصفت خط
المواجهه باكمله في منطقه دوناتس ما يمثل
تقليص لطموح الكريم لتامين القسم الاكبر
من الارض التي يدعي خضوعها للسياده
الروسيه وفقك
حاكم المنطقه قال انا وقع بالقرب من بلده
ضخمه
الروسيه تحاول التقدم نحو لمن التي
استعادتها القوه الاوكرانيه في
نوفمبرت بالكامل بفعل القصف الروسي اما
الرد الاوكراني فكان اطلاقا لوابل من
قاذفات الصواريخ في ضخمه واجزاء اخرى
وما يظهر شراسه المعارك المواجهه على بعد
100 متر فقط بين الجانبين وفق ما تحدثت
عنه صحيفه الجارديان نقلا عن جنود من
القوات الاوكرانيه الكريم لان قال انه
عازم على تامين الجزء الاكبر من الاراضي
في شرقي اوكرانيا وجنوبها على الاقل لكن
يبدو انه تخلى عن الاستيلاء على ارض اخرى
في الغرب والشمال الشرقي كانت كيا في
استعادتها فاسيطرت على ضخمت ان حدثت ستشكل
نجاحا للرؤوس الذين يتكبدون منذ الخريف
سلسله من الهزل وفي حال العكس ستكون هزيمه
جديده لموسكو على الساحه الاوكرانيه بلال
الوجدان العربيه